c'est gros tu n'es pas sortie avec un seul
gars depuis longtemps tu vides toute la
liste j'ai nettoyé le banc hé qu'est-ce qui ne
va pas la
gouvernante a appelé un tuyau éclaté dans la
salle de bain alors tu vas dans le Connecticut
maintenant je dois prendre une clé
je '  Je cherche Mark tu dois être sa
femme de ménage non je suis sa femme Kate est-ce
une sorte de marié strip-teaseuse ou quelque chose
ce qui s'est passé il a une femme et tu
ne penses pas que tu peux décoller es-tu pour de
vrai
je pensais que nous pourrions peut-être
dîner et vous laisser entrer nous ne buvons pas de
cosmos et nous nous tressons les cheveux
Je ne suis pas prêt à rivaliser avec des femmes comme
vous nous avons été joués par le même gars
tequila comment tu baises alors tu
dis que je devrais partir  alors qu'est-ce que
ton instinct te dit, ce qui
signifie que quelqu'un doit nous tromper tous les
deux parce que ce n'est pas moi ce qui se
passe salut je ne peux pas croire que tu mentirais tu
sens incroyable qu'est-ce que je pense que c'est
juste de la sueur alors nous voulons faire je veux
qu'il ressente de la douleur, nous devrions lui donner un coup de pied dans les
couilles non j'aime vraiment  la façon dont votre
cerveau fonctionne mais je pense que nous visons
quelque chose d'un peu plus grand
j'ai trouvé qu'il vole ses
partenaires
alors trouvons-leur de l'argent et ruinons-le
mettez l'avocat la femme et les seins
ensemble et nous savons comment le faire
aussi louche que lui je pensais que tu
lui donnais des hormones je ne suis pas pour un
look transsexuel pré-op je peux non plus ha
je pense que tu es en ménopause
mec opale ha est-ce un peu tu te
moques de moi
une maîtresse numéro 3  nous trouvons plus de
maîtresses je vais devoir l'envoyer en
cure de désintoxication tu es les amis les plus bizarres de tous les temps
nous sommes les amis les plus bizarres de tous les temps qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec ton beurre chaud non tu ne peux pas
avoir mon mari et mon frère qui
sont très gourmands